It takes a long time to make a human.
We can sometimes, I think, get caught up in
our own perceptions of how life works.
But there are some organisms that don’t
have the luxury of years and years of childhood.
No, for them, life is brief and they’ve
got to get on with living...and so sometimes
like with the gastrotrich, they’ll just
go ahead and have their first baby on the
day they’re born.
Now we’ve never had the chance to name a
species of microbe.
We name individuals all the time, this one’s
Neil.
But naming a species seems like both a thrilling
and weighty task.
You take this strange, new, tiny thing, and
you assign it an identity that it will never
know but that other human observers will come
to rely on, ostensibly forever.
And through the years, people who have faced
this challenge have turned to a wealth of
imagery and language to guide them.
There’s the multi-headed serpent of Greek
and Roman mythology, now also the name for
the multi-cellular, regenerating wonder of
Hydras.
Or you could go cuter, like the tardigrade,
which translates roughly to “slow stepper”
which also has the advantage of being accurate.
And then, you have Gastrotrichs, also known
by their phylum name Gastrotricha.
These organisms were not named in so flattering
a fashion.
No, Gastrostricha translates to “hairy stomachs.”
And when you don’t feel like saying “gastrotrich,”
you can also call them by their common name:
“hairy backs.”
But a rose is a rose by any other name, and,
truth is, they do have hairy stomachs.
And backs.
All, as we will see, for good reason.
But if their name doesn’t capture the mythological
glory that other organisms get, there are
moments, when the light hits just right and
bounces off their little scales, that Gastrotrichs
resemble iterations of one of the most pervasive
mythological figures of all time: the dragon.
We should scale back a bit though.
After all, gastrotrichs are among some of
the smallest metazoans, or we could say, less
esoterically...animals.
They range from around 60-500 micrometers
long, though in some very exceptional cases,
they might get up to several millimeters in
length.
There are two orders in the Gastrotricha phylum:
Chaetonida, which are mostly found in freshwater,
and Macrodasyida, which are found in marine
systems, though there are, weirdly, a few
freshwater species.
No matter what order they belong to, they
make up part of what’s called the meiofauna.
These are species grouped by their size.
Too big to be microfauna, too small to be
macrofauna, the meiofaunal organisms are between
60 micrometers to 2 millimeters—and they
play a deeply important ecological role, a
bridge between the micro and the macro, consuming
the former and being consumed by the latter.
They are a part of this system that brings
nutrients out from the microscopic world,
into the parts of ecosystems that we can directly
observe.
Gastrotrichs are among the most abundant species
present in the meiofauna.
In some habitats, it’s been estimated that
there are around 100,000 individual gastrotrichs
per square meter.
And there are around 860 known species counted
across both orders.
Now, that’s a lot of species of Gastrotrichs,
but it’s actually surprisingly low compared
to the diversity of other meiofaunal organisms.
There are, for example, over 2,000 rotifer
species, and approximately 40,000 species
of nematode.
Now this doesn’t mean anything bad for gastrotrichs—though it might be why they have yet to be found
in any extreme kind of habitat.
But it is remarkable that for microscopic
metazoans, 860 species is low when you put
it up against some other phyla.
Returning to their unfortunate but well-earned
name: the stomachs of gastrotrichs are covered
in hair-like cilia, which they use to glide
along surfaces as they dine on bacteria, algae,
and other small particles.
Unfortunately for us, it is hard to observe
and film these hairy stomachs because, well,
they swim with their bellies down
We’ve found that when we record gastrotrichs,
we have to be extra careful.
Their head is covered in cilia and mechanoreceptors
that seem to respond to any slight movement
in the water.
So it’s important not to create any accidental
vibrations in the microscope that might startle them.
Gastrotrich bodies are enclosed in a cuticle
and covered in spines or scales, or sometimes both.
And at the end of their bodies, many species
have a pair of feet, which hold adhesive tubes
that they can use to attach to grains of sand
or other objects.
And underneath the hairy, scaly cuticle, we
see the wonder of a multicellular body: a
brain, nervous system, simple gut, intestines,
muscles, and more.
Inside of this chaetonid gastrotrich is an
egg, and when that egg hatches, out will come
a new gastrotrich, fully developed with all
of those organs in place, and about 2/3 the
length of a full adult.
The fact that it hatches so formed is remarkable
on its own, but the whole reproductive cycle
of chaetonids is a marvel
Gastrotrichs are not particularly long-living
creatures.
Their life span is on the order of days to
weeks, which means they have to cram a lot
of living into a short amount of time.
When they hatch, chaetonids seem to immediately
begin developing their eggs through parthenogenesis,
a kind of cloning through which an unfertilized
egg is able to develop into an embryo that
is genetically the same as the parent.
In the species and conditions that chaetonid
reproduction has been most extensively documented
in, you might see a gastrotrich lay an egg
within a day after they themselves hatch.
And typically, they’ll lay 4 eggs within
4 days that can develop and hatch within a
day of being laid, producing genetically identical
offspring.
And those children are then out there themselves
laying eggs, meaning a gastrotrich can become
a grandmother just a few days after it was
born!
And here’s another weird thing...sometimes,
they lay a special kind of egg called an opsiblastic
egg, which has spines and is thicker and larger
compared to the other eggs, qualities that
keep it protected under harsher conditions.
Because of this rapid egg laying, we used
to think that chaetonids were entirely made
up of parthenogenetic females.
But later observations have revealed that
once these early eggs get laid, the chaetonids
become hermaphroditic, developing sperm and
eggs.
What they use the sperm for though is a mystery.
We just don’t have the observations we need
to understand how chaetonids make use of their
hermaphroditic phase.
This life history though characterizes just
the chaetonids.
Macrodasyoid gastrotrichs seem to all be hermaphroditic
except for one species, and so their process
is of course different.
And yet the result is the same: the direct
development of young gastrotrichs that contain
the full multicellular plan in their own body,
ready to create the next generation at birth.
It’s hard to know sometimes what to be most impressed by when you’re looking into the microcosmos.
Is it the giant unicellular organism, or the
tiny multicellular one?
Is it giving birth on the day you were born,
or the 40,000 species of nematodes..of course,
chances are, just minutes ago you had no idea
that the earth was covered in these tiny beasts,
bridging the words of the micro and macro,
and now we can’t even decide what the coolest
thing about them is.
Complexity is its own complex thing, so carry
on, our hairy-bellied friend.
And thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you especially to all of the people
on the screen right now who support us via Patreon.
These people allow us to continue diving into
these mysteries.
It’s a joy to do and we’re so happy that
you are compelled to help us out.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James, you can check him out
on Jam and Germs.
And if you want to see more from us, here
at Journey to the Microcosmos, you can find
us on twitter at twitter.com/journeytomicro
and you can also find us here on youtube at
youtube.com/microcosmos.